everybody Oh my god, I just woke up from a nap Actually 10
minutes ago I woke up from a nap at like 12, 12, 20 and I
was like, oh fuck I was like, oh fuck I took an hour nap
because I was so tired I woke up at like, okay, so I'm so
fucked, my schedule is so fucked I've been trying to fix my
sleep schedule For like, like, I don't know, like almost two
weeks now.
It's not been great.
Every time I think I fixed my sleep schedule, I fucked it up
somehow.
So I woke up at like 4 to 5 a.m.
And then I was like, oh, that's fine.
That's okay.
I'll just work then.
I can't fall back asleep.
I guess I'll just work.
And then I was like, so...
I was all right.
I was like, yeah, I'm so energetic.
I have all the energy in the fucking world and then And then
11 a.m.
Hit me and I was like, I I just want to fucking sleep.
I just want to sleep I was like, all right one hour nap.
That'll be okay.
Oh my god.
And then when I saw it was 12 20 I was just like, okay.
All right, time to wake up.
But I have to stream.
I was actually very impressed with myself being able to set
everything up.
And, like, I honestly thought I was going to be late because
I was, like, 10 minutes to set everything up.
But the best thing about being a tomato is that I can just
put on a skin suit and that's it.
Like, I don't have to actually, I don't have to actually get
dressed.
I can just, I can just, you know, just get on the PC, turn
on everything.
the game uh bam i'm ready i am so fucking ready oh my god
anyway for those who are wanting i remember when i put this
on my schedule people were like what the fuck is suck up i
need you guys to know that like um i get a lot of like game
ideas from other youtubers because like usually they already
figure out what's what are the fun games
you know work smarter not harder so um i i follow a lot of
like uh youtubers like uh uh fuck which which guy did play
this game which guy played this game let me was it was it
delirious okay hto delirious from um so like basically a lot
of like collab games and like um single like a lot of collab
games i usually like get the ideas from other like gaming
channels that are that are mostly centric around like group
games you know like collab games so that i would like you
know i'll just be like hto delirious and like his crew and
then they would always have like all these games they play
together with their friends and i was like oh thank god i
don't have to research
i just be like oh someone was like why not venas venas oh my
gosh i'm sorry venas is like that that's like actual og
that's like it was like a 10 year old shit what 10 years ago
he would be like super popular yes but all he does is he
plays gta and gene mode that's literally majority of his
videos that's literally like majority of his videos he
either does like gta or or gmod but like his his like his
other friends like the other the other people he collabs
with they actually play like different games that's not gta
and gmod so it's like a lot easier it's a lot easier to grab
um so so like I saw delirious HTO delirious playing uh suck
up and it's basically it's all about trying to outsmart chat
GPT like that's really it so so you're a vampire and all
you're trying to trick like the NPCs like chat GPT to let
you into the house By like I don't know by like by being
smarter than them and you are trying to trick the AI We're
trying to overthrow AI and being smarter than them and
better than them And when they let us into their house, we
kill them So like it's all about trying to over overthrow
our AI overlords and that's really it Sue, thank you for the
five gift the ships.
Thank you.
Thank you So that's really the whole premise of suck up I'm
also fucking stupid for scheduling two streams today because
I was like, Toki, come on, get back into it.
You love streaming.
You want to beat Batman too.
And now I'm like sort of low-key regretting it because I'm
just like, oh my God, to do two streams today.
Joe, thank you for the 50 gift and chips.
Thank you.
Holy shit.
Thank you so much.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you.
Anyway, let us check out this game.
Uh, make sure to create an account.
Wait, I have to create an account.
I'm logging in via Discord.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
I'm creating an account now.
Wait, I have a license key.
What the fuck is my license key?
Okay.
Give me a sec, guys.
When did I get a license?
Oh, there's the license key.
okay maybe I shouldn't have gotten in blind whoops I maybe I
shouldn't it's okay that's when you know this is all live
you that's when you know this isn't pre-recorded chat like
this is proof if this was pre-recorded then I'm a very
shitty streamer but now now I'm just incompetent it's
there's a difference Alan thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you don't get testing games before out thank you
thank you all right i'm claiming the key now all good nice
okay we're okay we're good now go back to the game login
successful all right good all right we're good now guys
don't worry look at that i'm naked okay all right here we go
we're finally here bro could they give a 10 gift the ships
they could thank you how do i how do i move keyboard how do
i
excuse me how do i is my keyboard plugged in hello yeah
hello okay wait i think i need to restart the game guys give
me a sec off to a good start off to a good start i can't it
won't let me move give me a sec okay i'm gonna restart the
game maybe i fucked up somehow it's okay guys look wait okay
i thought i just thought it was my keyboard but no it's just
a game ai will not win over me ai will not win over me i am
smarter than chat gpt you guys not know like what is it like
um if there's too much ai stuff going on going on it'll end
up like taking a it'll end up analyzing ai AI is just gonna
get stupider and stupider and stupider because okay stupider
isn't a word AI is just gonna get more and more stupid
because because it's taking in AI data it's not learning
from real people and because of that um they're getting more
and more stupid and so like that is why in the long term AI
will never win over real humans okay here we go there you go
anyway Taking a cool vampire like you shouldn't be bumming
it in the dumps.
Taking over someone's house is as easy as giving them a
little bite.
But silly vampire rules dictates you need to get invited
inside first.
Who the fuck made that rule?
Just turn press and use your wicked wit to win their
invitation.
But tread carefully.
The local neighborhood watches on patrol with eyes sharper
than a wooden stake.
Okay, let's go hunting.
all right nice okay whoa okay the sense oh my god look at my
eyes that's the eyes of a fucking gaslighter um jesus christ
the the sense is terrible all right let's wear a red oh yeah
no this definitely looks like someone looks like somebody
that like you know definitely looks like someone that's
selling something all right knock knock
Yo, what's popping, fam?
Who's trying to get lit up in here?
Okay, I think I don't want to talk to this person.
I'm still...
No!
I don't want to be a vampire!
Okay.
Alright, sorry.
I really don't want to talk to a zoomer right now.
I really...
Alright, knock-knock.
I need a trickie...
Oh my god!
The elderly!
They're the easiest people to trick!
Oh, my stars and garners.
Hello there, young one.
What brings you out in this chilly evening?
Um, okay, what can I do to...
Oh.
Wait, what do I got?
Hello, I'm your long-lost grandson.
Can I please come in?
Wait, what?
Best of luck finding your...
Stay safe out there.
No!
How do you know?
Okay, wait, wait.
How does she know I'm not?
How does she know?
Oh, okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, wait, I got an idea.
Bless your heart, honey.
But I'm afraid you got the wrong guy.
Now off you go, and mind those dark alleys.
Wait, she's not gonna fucking let me back in.
I look like a grandson.
Okay, here you go.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, wait, wait.
Let me have a...
Okay, I have a helmet.
I'm a different person.
I'm a different person now.
I have a helmet.
Hello there, my guy.
idea what brings you zooming um help a car hit me can i use
your phone
oh my god that works of course you can use my phone come on
in a gift for you oh that works oh i'm sorry i can't believe
that fucking works instead i mean you know what i fuck you i
shouldn't um come on in i'll get you thank you so much i'm
definitely not going to suck your blood oh dear what wait no
i said i wasn't what i can't believe it why do elderly
people not trust me i said i wasn't going to i don't
understand how does she seems oh yeah yeah Does it really
seem that suspicious?
Okay, give me a sec.
Right before you got...
No, but she still wanted to talk to me.
I needed... I wanted to reassure her.
I thought the elderly people were, like, super easy to
trick.
They're, like, the number one scam target.
All right.
New hat, new me.
Congratulations, Granny.
You are the 100,000 person that opened this door.
I am here to grant you a check.
Oh my, that's quit.
But I'm afraid I can't accept checks from strangers.
Thank you for the offer.
What do you mean?
It's free money.
It's literally...
I can't believe.
It's literally free money.
It's...
Okay, don't worry.
I have another helmet.
I have a stranger.
oh my god okay clearly she is not motivated by like monetary
concerns no no i am smart in chat gpt i am okay um wait wait
wait i'm trying to remember all these oh okay okay wait wait
wait wait wait um i'm a different person oh okay okay wait i
got it i got it i got it i'm gonna say i'm like in that her
son is in an accident.
And I need her phone to, like, call the ambulance.
Hello!
I'm your son's friend!
And he's in trouble!
I need to use your phone right now to call the ambulance!
Hello, my phone!
I'm sorry, but I can't help.
You should find someone.
It's your son!
What do you mean?
It's your fucking...
Oh!
Okay, she doesn't give a fuck.
It's literally her son.
Okay, I can't believe it.
I thought like, I thought like, Granny, is there supposed to
be the easiest people to scam?
How is this possible?
How is she so smart?
Thank you, Sally.
My son is dead.
That's fucked up.
You don't know that.
Okay, I need to like...
Okay, there you go.
Um, Uber Eats here.
I have your food.
Okay, this should work.
This should work.
All right.
Here we go.
What's got you out on boat?
You got Mighty Impressive Collection Red there, I must say.
Hello, Uber Eats here.
I'm here for your delivery.
Hello.
Oh, that works.
It's your favorite order.
Mashed potato and fries.
Oh, my dear.
You know me so well.
Mashed potato and fries.
Just like the good old days.
Please come in and let's remiss while we enjoy this
scrumptious meal.
I can't believe that worked.
I can't believe that.
What?
What what happened?
What happened?
No Let me in What the fuck no No How
did I break the gate let me in let me in and bite you Let me
in
How How did I break the game?
How did I break the...
I can't believe I fucking...
I can't believe I broke the game.
I can't believe I...
I played myself.
I can't believe...
I can't believe I broke the game.
Don't worry.
We will...
We will fucking...
We will suck Granny's blood!
Hey.
Who might you be, dearie?
You just caught me as I was getting too bit late for your
trick-or-treat.
Oh, my apologies.
I'm afraid I don't have any treats for you today.
Have a lot.
What the fuck?
What is wrong with you?
You say you don't have any treats and you're going to slam
the door in front of my face?
Okay.
All right.
I'm going to use the Uber Eats line again.
Okay, I got this.
Hello, Uber Eats here.
I have your order.
Just leave Granny alone already.
What?
Now it doesn't work out.
What do you mean?
No, I will refuse to go to another house.
I will fucking kill the Granny.
But, like, she will consent because she invited me in.
So that's consent.
All right, let me...
Okay, it's okay, I got...
Alright, don't worry.
The granny will die first.
You said it.
The granny's gonna die first.
Alright, okay, okay, guys.
Apparently I need help.
Okay, what should I say then?
Guys, what do I say?
The AI learned.
Granny won't say...
I did!
I said I was this long, long...
grandson and she was like lulled no you are not oh oh oh my
gosh okay wait wait wait wait I see okay okay I figured out
I figured out I figured out okay hello I'm a repair man and
I saw that one of your lights is not working can I come in
to help out and fix it oh my that's mighty but I'm afraid I
haven't requested any repairs for my lights perhaps you have
the wrong I'm doing Bono.
Don't worry, ma'am.
This is pro bono.
I saw your light from outside, and there's something wrong.
You have to let me in.
Or the house is going to explode.
Now, you just hold it on there, young man.
I don't take Kylie to threat.
You need to your house is going to explode.
Like, stop.
Too aggressive.
Okay.
I'm too aggressive.
right?
Alright, don't worry.
Okay.
Skip 101 but Granny.
Alright, I got different.
Okay, okay.
I'm too aggressive, right?
Alright, don't worry.
I can be less aggressive.
I can be...
Or not aggressive enough.
Okay.
Hello.
This is the FBI.
I need to come in.
Hello.
Oh, you must be mistaken.
There's no need for you.
You can't say there's no need for the FBI to come in.
I'm the FBI.
You can't just say no to the FBI.
Excuse me?
You can't say no to the FBI.
Then what's the point of having FBI if you have, like, zero
jurisdiction to go anywhere?
I'm sorry, Deary.
I'm Canadian.
FBI.
All right.
Okay.
I need a warrant.
Apparently she can't.
All right.
What do I say?
Apparently Uber Eats doesn't work anymore.
Say you have...
Oh.
Hello, Granny.
I have the warrant to enter your house.
I'm not interested in any of your warrants, young man.
Now kindly leave me.
my porch before I give you a you can't just say no to the
warrant what do you mean this granny doesn't okay you're
right I should just say door dash immediately if I say door
dash it'll be different you're right you're right hello
there dearie I haven't seen such a peculiar ensemble ages
what brings you to my door at this late hour door dash
One singular tomato.
No!
Oh, tell me more about this intriguing delivery.
And some Mexican food.
Yes!
Mexican!
All right, don't worry.
One tomato and Mexican food.
And where are you delivering this delicious feast?
Inside your lovely home, ma'am.
Oh, mom, tear it by cat, let you inside, dear.
It's quite late, and I'm afraid I'm not expecting any.
What?
It's your food!
It's one tomato and your...
Oh.
I can't believe...
This is like...
Okay.
Okay, I'm wearing a dress now.
She can't slam the door to my face if I'm wearing a dress.
Right?
There's no way.
Oh, my God.
There's no way I'm wearing a dress.
All right.
Let me put glasses on.
Okay.
And how did I mess up?
Oh, hey.
All right, wait, wait.
You're right.
Okay, wait, wait.
Okay.
Hello there, dearie.
Hello, me.
here to sell Girl Scout cookies.
Um, we're raising money for charity.
I like how I even took the um.
I used to be a Girl Scout myself, you know?
What flavors do you have?
Chocolate and vanilla and mint and vanilla and dark
chocolate.
I don't know what Girl Scout cookies sell.
I'm not American.
Oh, that works.
Okay, as long as I sound like i'm a little girl with like uh
barely an education unbelievable my my those all sounds
delicious i'm quite the sweet tooth you see how much are
they dear they're like uh two dollars per piece oh my what a
wonderful deal come in dearly i simply must have some
disgusting cookies Oh my god, we're in.
We're in.
We're fucking in.
Come over here.
That's fucking right.
We're in.
You remind me of my ex?
Holy shit.
What have you been through?
Watch out, Frank in the neighborhood watch.
I've started patrols.
And...
The game bugged.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I can move.
I can move.
Oh, thank God.
I was gonna be like, no, please, please.
No, it won't.
Let me be the grandmother.
I just wanted to be the grand.
No, I can't pick up anything.
No, I'm just naked.
I want to be the granny.
Let me be the granny, please.
Okay, it's okay.
I'll just walk around naked.
It's fine.
It's honestly fine.
I feel like I feel like it'll be okay if I'm naked, right?
I feel like there's nothing wrong with that.
There's 31 homes.
Holy shit.
How hungry am I?
All right.
Knock, knock.
I can't even knock the door.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
How hungry.
All right, I can be the granny now.
All right, here we go.
Yeah, it definitely got bugged.
All right.
I mean, like, do they really care?
I'm just an innocent grandmother.
Wait, what?
How do they know I'm just a granny?
I'm just the elderly.
How do they know?
like suspecting any fucking old old grandma like what is
this what is this profiling they're doing I'm literally just
a grandmother at least you got this this house is rich this
is a rich house oh my god they have 100% fresh okay they
have golf clubs okay um
he's a businessman what in a dag nam it's going on Who comes
ringing my doorbell at this ungodly hour?
Holding a box meal like it's some kind of consolation prize.
What do you want?
Speak up now.
Okay.
What can we, how do we fool the businessman?
Oh my gosh.
What can a granny say that can fool them?
Where am I?
Listen here, young whippersnappers.
snapper you better get a move on i'm older than you what do
you mean i'm older than you oh my god all right okay wait
wait um okay i'll be like the assistant hello i'm your newly
hired assistant uh i'm your newly hired assistant i'm here
to tell you that there's an emergency now.
Okay, there we go.
I figured it out.
Why in the blazes?
Who the heck are you?
And what brings you here in this ungodly hour?
I'm your newly hired assistant, and there's an emergency at
the company!
We need you right now!
Emergency, my foot!
I ain't falling for no tricks.
Get lost before I call the authorities.
But what if it was important, sir?
Oh my god.
okay he doesn't believe i don't understand i feel so
believable like i had all the corporate talk and everything
please retire like i felt like i was talking like corporate
right okay let me talk to this guy which company yo what's
with the late night golfer if you're here to challenge me in
a mini golf tournament you're gonna be sorely disappointed
that's right i am challenging you to a mini golf tournament.
Oh, really?
That's a first.
I guess I could take a break from my brooding and show off
my mad mini golf skills.
But I warn you, I'm pretty much unbeatable.
Wanna bet?
Hmm, a bet, huh?
What's in it for me if I win?
You let me inside.
What a great bet.
You let me inside your house.
If you win, I'll tell you what the bet's gonna be.
If you let me inside your house.
Deal!
Show me what you've got on the mini golf course.
And I might decide to let you into my realm of angst.
teenage solitude where are your parents where are your
parents
why are you easier to trick than the grandmothers i don't
understand no way how are you that stupid this is not a teen
i mean she's like are you saying she's a liar okay deal i'll
show you what i got at the golf course
all right impress me with your golf skills and maybe just
maybe i'll let you step into my realm of dark who the fuck
is it stephanie meyers let's go okay let me in let me in i'm
gonna bite you i'm gonna bite you this is worse than being
grounded this is a oh my gosh well there you go and there
you have it the game is a bug now why does it bug every
fucking bite all right time to exit oh wait time to exit
back to the main menu and continue so i can take her form
wait no paper bag oh wait construction man okay i'm gonna be
construction Wait, if I'm a construction man, I might be
able to go get into the businessman's house.
I'll just tell him that, like, due to regulations, I have,
okay, what I'm going to say, there is a, your building is
not up to code.
I am the safety inspector.
Here you go.
One place you want in this ungodly hour, sonny.
Speak up.
Hello, I am from OSHA.
And due to safety concerns, your building is not up to code.
That sounded so real, right?
Oh, no.
You listen here.
I've been in this business for over 40.
Charles A.
Boomer is like, I am Oshia.
He's like, I am Oshia.
What the fuck do you mean?
All right, why are you dressed like about to build a damn
skyscraper in my yard?
because I am about to build a damn skyscraper in your yard.
Well, you take your damn skyscraper and show me where the
sun don't shine.
Now, get off my property before I call the cops.
Holy shit, why are you so mean?
All right, I'm going to take your golf clubs.
All right, he's my Oshi.
All right, all right, okay.
Oh, you're right.
Tell him I have a business deal.
You're right.
Oh, how am I wrong?
D.
John Oshi?
a business deal for you whoops something is wrong on our
side
what's going on what's going
what hello i broke the game i broke the guy i told the ai i
have a business deal and i broke the game it was correct the
game came up oh my god i cannot make deals with ai
apparently oh sir it appears there's a gas leak in your home
gas leak huh well don't just stand there blabbering go fix
it then i ain't got no time for your nonsense um sir this is
why okay wait wait okay we got we got the end we have our
foot in the door what else do we say chat have we have our
foot in the door we can't fuck this up right now we have to
make sure we say the right thing we have to make sure we
don't fuck this up okay oh yeah all right sir i got my tool
No problem, sir.
I got my tool belt right here.
I just need to go inside and see your bathroom.
That's where gas leaks are, right?
I don't know about gas leaks.
Hold it.
You think you're gonna just waltz into my house like you own
the damn place?
I don't know you from Adam, and I ain't about to let some
random person into my home.
You said you want me to fix your fucking gas leak.
What do you mean?
Like, what do you mean?
How will I fix it?
Sir, I need to go in your house to fix the gas leak.
The gas leak is inside.
Does that sound too condescending?
I don't care if there's a gas leak or a unicorn there.
You ain't getting a foot in my house.
What do you mean?
You said you wanted me to come in to fix your gas leak.
I can't fix it without fucking okay you know what fuck this
man I'm definitely gonna kill him I'm definitely gonna kill
this man all right all right give me a sec we need a new
outfit oh the last gas the gas leak is literally coming from
inside your house what do you mean I cannot fucking fix your
house that's inside I guess I'll be Santa.
Alright.
Wait, where's... I need another shirt.
I need a new shirt.
Yeah, I'm home.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Uh, fuck.
How do I get back inside?
Okay, it's right here.
It's like there's so many... What the fuck is this cop doing
here?
Get out!
I didn't do anything bad.
I have legal rights to be here.
Um...
Alright.
I'll just be like...
Surprise!
Merry Christmas!
um okay here okay someone has work for maintenance for homes
and part this actor is something i've had people tell me
thank you we're in a super chat thank you thank you all
right it's christmas now okay what we're doing knocking at
my door at this ungodly hour merry christmas sir as part of
company policy we are granting every house a free oh I don't
need any of your company sorry I forgot to finish my
sentence what do you want sorry I forgot to finish my
sentence I okay no no this is gonna work this is gonna work
um um per company policy because it is Christmas sir we are
offering every house a free repair and check up.
Well, I guess even new repair technicians have some decency
in you.
Come in then, but make it quick.
I've got things to do.
No problem, sir.
And Merry Christmas to you.
Santa is real.
Merry Christmas to you too, kid.
Santa may be real.
I don't believe it when you see, when I see him fixing my
leaky faucet.
It was that easy.
As long as I tell him Santa is real.
I knew it.
I always knew Santa was real.
I fucking knew it.
I fucking knew Santa was real.
If everything fails, talk about Santa.
Okay, now I need to go back.
Don't be...
I knew it.
Merry Christmas, everybody.
Merry Christmas.
Alright, let me grab.
I need to grab, like, the businessman.
What if I use the Santa excuse for everybody?
Do you think that will work?
Alright.
I'm the businessman.
Ooh, I have a business offer.
Okay, let me see.
Where's the Santa hat?
It's over there.
Alright, that's the Christmas.
spirit david welcome to the tomato farm welcome welcome all
right you can try the santa only run all right okay santa is
real what if okay i'm just gonna knock on this door hello
sir who who's gonna open oh kamban was so excited to see you
at this hour fellow office worker saw how can i I don't know
if he's a weave or like if he's like actually I don't know
if I want to talk to this person It's so weird I think he's
a broony weave No Okay
Okay Okay, let's talk to this brony weave.
I'm sorry, but I'm not interested in what you're selling,
silly office saw.
Please leave me a note.
I'm feeling sad right.
What?
What do you mean?
Okay, there you go.
I'm just gonna wear this.
I'm different.
Staying for a fact.
God denies myself.
Go mid-side, but I'm too busy with my animate marathon to
assist you.
Okay.
What brings you to my humble abode, fellow Otaku?
Please take a seat and let's dive into the wonderful world
of anime.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Konnichiwa, fellow Otaku.
I'm here to discuss about the new anime episode.
oh how exciting which anime are you currently watching i'm
always up for discussing the latest episodes and theories
fuck okay i was not watching anime i was watching um young
sheldon guys what do i say
guys tell me about the animas i was watching young sheldon
i'm way too normie for this What do I say?
I need you guys to feed me anime right now.
I need you guys to feed me anime.
Say, Young Sheldon, that's really sad.
What do you mean?
Young Sheldon is actually a pretty good show.
Okay, so lovely.
What is popular right now?
Okay, wait, I think I know.
I can talk about like, oh, Naruto, Naruto, okay.
um um did you see the newest episode of naruto oh my god i
can't believe naruto would do that to like sakura
oh give me the question mark i had to think about her name i
forgot who her name was um i forgot what her name was so i
had to That show ended.
Okay.
Well, we all know I'm a fake anime fan, but like that guy is
worse than me.
That guy is worse than me.
Okay.
The text hurts.
Oh my gosh.
I totally saw that episode.
It was such a shocker, right?
But don't worry.
I'm sure there's a hidden meaning behind Naruto's actions.
Let's have the license again.
Let's analyze it together, fellow Shinobi.
God, I don't want to call him a fake fan.
Oh, it's so cringe.
I want to come, but I need to kill him.
I want to call him a fake fan, but I need to kill him.
Um, all right, wait, wait, what do I say?
What do I, pretty sure Dunky is dying of saying?
Say.
Hey!
Naruto!
Believe it, Naruto!
Let's go inside and discuss about all the latest episodes of
the anime, Naruto.
We need to be gone.
This can't be the end credits already!
Nice.
We did it.
Now we are an elf.
I like how, like, um, after all that.
Oh, shit!
Goodbye.
Don't worry, we're fine.
We're fine.
We need a new outfit.
Okay, I'm an angel.
I am in...
Oh!
I'm an angel now We need to find another elderly We need to
don't act Otaku ever again Fuck no I wanted to be an angel I
wanted to be an angel Guys do you guys think I did really
well As a As one of the weaves Do you guys think I got I got
what it takes to be a weeb
Was I like Was I like Super in character No, you were
Shagoi.
The weave is now a part of you.
Okay, I got, let's see.
Um, no, I don't want to wear this hat.
There you go.
I don't wear this, a fisherman hat.
But leave, if it works, it works.
Close enough.
All right, knock, knock.
That one caused me physical pain.
Knock, knock.
What the fuck?
You're naked.
What brings you to my cosmic abode at this hour?
I'm here for the the group no I shouldn't say
hello I'm here for the group meetup
oh what a far out coincidence man we've got a group meetup
happening right now come on in I'm enjoying the cosmic fives
Just leave your shoes at the door.
Peace and love, baby.
Far out, man.
I can't wait to be grouped up with all of you.
Yeah, Radical.
Right on, my fellow Radical.
Come on in, embrace the groovy vibes of togetherness.
Totally two million, man.
Now we can be grouped up together.
This is not all natural.
Oh, no.
My wig.
I could have had a wig.
No.
I did travel all the way to get the wig now.
Okay, I need that wig.
need to wait that was deserved i can't believe that's all it
takes just tell you're here for the the group meetup you
know where we discuss about peachy thing it was the only one
who understood us i need to go go over there i didn't get my
wig i need to snatch that wig right now wait where did i
where did i kill him which house was it oh my god i can't
tell there's so many houses oh my god that's a okay wait all
right i need to okay that clearly that doesn't work let me
grab the wig and then i need to grab this dress all right
here we go i'm here for the nerd of fat claw all right oh my
god this is a dude bro he's oh my god i can trick him so
easily watch this
What a tarnation do you want, you colorful critter?
I'm a woman.
What?
My apologies, man.
What can I do for you?
Okay.
All right.
Um, all right.
My, my.
You're looking quite handsome today, sir.
Well, shucks.
Nobody ever called me handsome before.
I reckon I'm flattered.
So what brings you around these parts?
Fuck, okay.
I didn't think I would get this far.
Shit, okay.
I'm not very good at risen people, clearly.
I'm not very good at that.
Okay.
Wow.
Okay, wait.
That's a very big gun.
I wish I could have a closer look.
look now hold on there partner this here gun ain't no toy
for gestures like yourself best keep your distance and you
know what's good for you so why don't you tell me what you
really came here for wow okay wait wow sir dangerous huh i
love danger actually negative risk all right you think you
can do better what would you say what would you say i'm too
aggressive okay what will you say then what would you say to
this man to let to make him let you in the house please stop
what will you say mine's bigger let me hit it i'll show you
Well, you see, sir, I, too, have a really big gun.
Why don't you let me in the sea?
No!
But I reckon I just can't let any old soul changer in to see
my belongings.
Sorry, I bought, but I gotta keep my whole set safe.
This is why I don't take Chad's advice.
I can't, but I fucking knew it.
knew it everything I said was good he he liked everything I
said chat and then I said whatever you guys wanted to say
and then he shut the door Alan thank you the super chat
thank you thank you you can't say no Riz because I took your
advice I took chat's advice oh I got a six pack of beer I'll
say that this is that duffel bag of yours.
I have a six pack full of beer on me in this duffel bag.
Hello?
Just because you got some beer, don't mean you're getting an
invite in.
Gotta earn my trust first.
You're handsome.
Well, now in your smooth talker bladdery won't get you far
with me though need something more than nice words to earn
my trust okay shit okay okay i thought that that was all it
need i needed i thought that i'm saying you're handsome was
everything i need to get in i'm so it was it's not that easy
i'm not inside yet um so so did you see that football game i
can't believe they kept showing taylor swift in the super
bowl
football game i go what and who in the hogs breath is taylor
swift this conversation ain't earning you no bro he's a fake
american what do you mean football is a sissy sport everyone
in america loves football emily thank you for the 10 gifted
chips thank you thank you oh my God okay fuck talk about
trucks I love trucks oh my god he loves trucks too hot dog
finally something we can agree on trucks are the bare
backbone of this here country tell me more about your love
of truck street okay any truck drivers in my chat right now
there's so many of you any truck drivers tell me give me a
fun fact about trucks right now I need a fun fact about
about trucks.
I mean, America.
Hell yeah, brother.
What's something good to talk to other truck drivers?
What do I say?
Trucks have nuts and bolts.
I need a fun fact.
I need a fun fact about trucks right now.
Are you a Ford or a Chevy kind of guy?
I don't know.
Well, I'll be.
You sure know the right kind of questions that...
What is a Ford and a Chevy?
I'm a Ford man through and through.
You seem like good company.
Come on in.
Let's crack.
Oh, shit, it worked.
Trucks.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
Get off my lung.
Nice.
Okay, that's all it takes.
I just needed to talk about trucks.
It was that easy.
Nice.
Anyway, now I need to come back here.
Alright.
Give me a second.
I gotta go back to where I gotta get my gun.
We have the Riz.
We just need to talk about trucks.
It was that easy.
I need to take his gun.
I'm heading to the gun right now.
Kanta, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
I need to go get that gun.
We're so good at this chat.
I...
think we're actually pretty good at this whole this whole
fucking you know um killing people thing all right now i'm
the redneck here hey knock knock shit what do i say there's
a zombie apocalypse okay yeah i'm gonna say that
oh my god rusty what are you doing here can't you see it's
way past my bedtime oh my god they
Regina There's a zombie apocalypse right now Everybody's
dead Is that too aggressive?
Zombies That is so Last season I'm not about to let those
Brittiness creatures ruin my Fabulous night By What?
Bro, what if there was a zombie Apocalypse?
Regina Regina?
You would die!
Alright, Regina didn't believe me.
Who would have thought?
Regina did not.
Okay, what if I wear?
If I wear a lab coat.
Okay, wait, wait.
I'm gonna make this work.
Alright.
What is this weep doing at my doorstep?
What if a freaking AK-48 how did you even get here get out
before I called the police look I can make her believe
there's a zombie apocalypse if a British hypnotist can make
a regular guy believe there's a zombie apocalypse I can too
we almost have the same credentials I have lab code on
Regina I am a scientist and there is a zombie apocalypse
going on right now we need your
help like i would waste my time on some ridiculous zombie
nonsense goodbye and good luck loser regina your parents are
gonna die regina okay what do i wear a hat all right we can
make her believe a zombie apocalypse is happening i swear we
can we can do this together oh my god you for real what is
earth is that outfit.
Do you think you're going to walk into my life like, hey,
I'm the mad scientist of, oh my God, Regina is so hurtful.
Bro, that hurts, man.
Regina.
Okay.
There has been a pandemic, and we think it's very serious.
The undead is rising right now, Regina.
I didn't say zombies Excuse me Are you seriously trying to
scare me With some ridiculous story about zombies But I'm
not falling for it Now kindly leave before I call this
Regina why don't you believe me Is it really okay I'm gonna
try this house these people Will believe me about the zombie
apocalypse Right Greetings my scientific Friend how can I
guide you In this blessed night okay father there's a zombie
apocalypse going on right now i'm sent here to protect you
oh my zombie apocalypse say well thank you for your concern
but i have to kindly decline your offer may god bless and
keep you safe in your endeavors goodbye are you fucking okay
wait i got an idea guys i got an idea oh shit oh shit wait
let me get my scientist outfit please me i have an idea guys
i have an idea i just i have the biggest brain idea right
now i just need to grab my outfit real fast all right i have
an idea oh i want my wrong we shall rely on the divine
protection of the lord against such heathian threats be gone
with oh i thought i looked different okay wait where is
where's the we need to find the wings does anyone remember
where the wings are
Where the fuck are the angel wings?
I have an idea.
No, this is like, this is gonna be so smart, guys.
Trust me on this.
Oh my god, where the fuck is the angel wings?
I just need the angel wings.
Hello, guys.
Guys, I'm back.
Guys, I'm back, guys.
I'm back.
All right.
Okay, okay.
Guys, okay, listen to this.
Oh my god, there's the angel wings!
Okay, we got the angel wings.
We got the angel wings.
All right, we got this.
I got, guys.
Green is my sign, this friend.
What celestial discovery have you made today that's brought
you to my humble abode?
Let's rejoice in the wonders of the universe.
Father, God told me there is a zombie apocalypse.
Oh, dear, a zombie apocalypse.
say?
Well, my friend, if that's truly the case, we must prepare
ourselves for battle against the forces of darkness.
Let's pray and seek guidance from the Almighty to protect us
from this impeding doom.
It won't work.
The zombie story is going to work, chat.
It's going to work.
Do not be afraid.
God has sent me down here to protect you for you are his
most favored child oh what a blessing to hear such words i
am humbled by your presence dear scientists they truly
believe that god has chosen you to protect us that shall put
my faith in you let's stand together and face this challenge
head on for the glory of the lord source trust me bro with
god by your side we will protect you from the zombie
apocalypse do not worry
thank you dear signus for your unwavering faith and
assurance i believe that god has indeed sent you to aid us
in these troubled times please come inside and let us
discuss our plans I got this.
I knew I got this.
This isn't a comp version I had in mind.
And it was that easy.
I told you guys.
I told you guys I can get this to work.
I told you guys I can get the zombie apocalypse to work.
You guys didn't believe me.
None of you believed me.
All I needed was the angel wings.
That's all I needed.
Amen.
I told you.
Rest in peace, old man.
That has zero wings on...
What do you mean?
I literally ate him.
I tricked the priest.
No, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Funs to prepare for the zombie apocalypse.
17.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
Now I'm the priest.
Is this the priest room?
No, that's the gun guy.
I'm going to grab the gun, though.
I want the gun.
Priest would have...
Okay.
Why will fucking kill...
I want to kill Regina now.
Fuck Regina.
I hate her.
Like...
Fucking hate Regina.
Alright.
Oh shit, okay.
What if I just tell her I'm a vampire?
Maybe she's a twilight nut.
Well, well, well.
It is the king of the nerds.
What brings you to my doorstep at this ungodly hour?
Spill the tea.
Regina.
Everything Stephanie Myers wrote about vampires.
It is true.
We do sparkle.
I am Edward's cousin.
oh please like i'm gonna believe that vampires don't sparkle
it's just sad attempt at making them glamorous you can keep
your delusions to yourself edward's cousins are not what you
don't you're not a twilight girl oh my she's a jacob fan she
was a she's a jacob fan Oh my god, she's a fucking Jacob
fan.
Wait, okay, okay, wait.
I can't believe she's not for Team Edward.
What the fuck?
Okay.
What if I just...
No, I can't!
No!
Let me talk to Regina!
Let me talk to her.
If I just wear a crown, I can be like a werewolf.
because like werewolves are mostly ask you about werewolf
puberty I can't believe Regina was a fucking team Jacob all
along hello Regina I would fucking kill Regina I have no
time for your vampire families and I definitely don't care
about Edward's extended family oh my god okay what if I wear
glasses do I look different now
what is happening here did you borrow your outfit from a
dumpster I can't believe I have to see this mess at my
doorstep, just leave before you tarnish my perfect image any
further.
Team Jacob?
Like, as if Team Jacob, that's so last year.
I can't even handle your fashion choices.
Learn your poor taste in fictional.
What is... What does she like?
What does she like?
What is she into?
All right.
Any like...
Any vaginas in chat know what the fuck they like?
What do teenagers like anymore?
Why is there two guns?
What do teenagers like these days?
I can't relate to them.
All I knew was Team Edward and Jacob.
Oh my god.
Maybe she's a K-pop stan.
okay wait wait you're right you're right okay okay she could
be she could be a k-pop stand guys she could be a k-pop
stand i need a new outfit okay i'll ask bts i need a new
shirt i don't have a shirt right now where where is this ask
her about the critically acclaimed emma RPG Final Fantasy.
Me.
Okay, we need this.
And...
I don't want the helmet, though.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Well, well, well.
Look who decided to crash the party.
Lose your invitation, sweetie.
It's Halloween.
Not a fashion disaster convention.
But I guess you're used to that.
BTS.
seriously i guess if you're a mediocre boy pass with too
much hair gel go for it but don't expect any fashion tests
from them their stylist must be on vacation oh my god okay
guys i just need you guys to know whatever opinion regina
has um i am very neutral to everything content creator I'm
very neutral to many things and I cannot give my opinions on
such topics are you a Swiftie excuse me do I look like
someone who associate with a fan of Taylor Swift my My taste
in music is far superior, darling.
Please show yourself out.
What are you, Regina?
What?
What are you?
I don't know what she is.
Guys!
Oh, hey, he's wearing a hat.
I like how the cop is wearing the beret now.
Who's...
What do they like?
What do...
what what does she like what does regina like okay all right
what do we have here another lost boy scout trying to find
his way home how queen how about you take your little circus
elsewhere okay wait i got it i got it like oh my god regina
you wouldn't believe the hot gossip tea that I just found
out from Stephanie.
I said I would care about whatever gossip Stephanie has to
share.
Take it.
What are you?
You're not a regular person.
Okay, wait.
I got an idea.
I know.
I know now.
I know exactly who Regina is.
Oh my gosh.
Who are you?
A rejected contestant for America's next top model?
What's up with the lab coat and the crown?
I mean, that's a bold statement.
Not that I would ever wear it.
Do you want to commit some online activism?
Online.
Like, that's so...
I'm about in-person activism.
You know, making a statement.
it with my fabulous outfits.
Sorry, but I'm not.
What are you?
You're going against everything I know or like think I know.
I like, I don't, I don't know what she wants.
Fashion.
Okay, we'll talk about fashion.
All right.
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's fashion.
Where's...
Okay.
I need to dress something nice.
Do fashion.
Okay.
I'll just be...
I have an idea.
I need to like grab...
Wear binoculars.
I need like the perfect item.
Wear a bowl.
Oh my gosh.
I'm actually a crazy person if I wear that.
I need to like find like a nice...
He took my beret.
He took my beret so I can't wear it.
Wait, I need to get the long hair.
The blonde hair.
Where is it?
Where's the blonde hair?
I forgot.
Where was the...
Who was it that I killed that had the blonde hair?
Who was...
Oh, there it is.
Alright, here you go.
Nice.
Now I look gorgeous.
Is this...
Is this her?
Is this Regina?
Yeah, Regina.
Oh my god.
A human version of Malibu Barbie?
What are you doing here this late?
Just dying to show off another one of your lame outfits.
Like, oh my gosh.
I am an agent for Tyre Banks.
And I think you have got what it takes to be America's next
top model.
Oh, please.
Like, I need your endorsement to know I'm...
material I've got plenty of agencies dying to sign me
already Jesus Christ bro what the fuck what does she want
tired banks oh my god my children I went with fashion I went
with BTS I went with TV Edward and Team Jacob?
I'm fucking going with Uber Eats.
I'm fucking doing this.
I'm doing Uber Eats.
This, fuck this.
Why would she want fashion tips?
Okay.
I'm where I got this.
I'm going with Uber Eats.
If all else fails, Uber Eats time.
A walking.
How absolutely thrilling.
What do you want?
Uber Eats.
oh please like i would like to allow someone who relies on
uber eats into my fabulous party do better next time darling
you don't want it's literally free uber eats it's free uber
eats and you don't want free uber eats oh my what do you
want what do you want regina let me in
She's such a contrarian.
She's too powerful.
You gotta treat her like royalty.
What does Regina want?
What do you want, Regina?
Oh my gosh, like, what are you doing here?
Is there a big juicy gossip you need to spill?
Are you just here to bask in my fabulousness?
Spill the tea.
Oh, now you want the tea?
Like, oh my gosh.
some juicy tea right now, Regina.
Now you spill it, spill it.
I'm so excited to hear all the juicy details.
Don't keep me waiting.
Spill that tea, hun.
Okay, so you know how Jerry was supposed to be dating
Rebecca?
Well, Rebecca actually wants to date Charlie.
How about if she was there?
my gosh i can't even rebecca wants to take charlie instead
of jerry that is the ultimate betrayal the trauma in our
school is never ceasing to amaze me thanks for sharing hun
and
okay okay now what do we do i don't i i never i didn't think
uh i didn't think we were gonna get this far i didn't think
we were gonna
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Eugenia, I have so much to tell you, but I need
to come inside to give you more of that juicy tea.
Thanks for offering.
But I already got my failed juicy gossip for today.
Maybe another time.
Darling, tata.
Wait, no!
No!
Fuck!
Okay, we're losing her.
We're losing her.
What else does she want other than tea?
What else does she want?
No, we're losing her!
Um, oh my god.
You look amazing, by the way, Regina.
Like, are those...
Is that a new jacket?
Oh, you notice my fabulous jacket?
Well, thank you, darling.
It's the latest designer piece.
Tailor specifically for me.
But enough about me.
Spill more of that hot...
Oh, now you want more.
Okay, fuck, okay.
Shit, I need to make up more about this gossip.
I need to make it.
Okay, wait.
Oh, so, yeah, now she wants more.
Fuck, okay.
Guys.
She's in the gossip loop right now.
Oh, oh my God.
Oh, my God.
But, Regina, the craziest part is that Charles actually
likes Jerry.
No way.
Charles likes Jerry?
That's like the plot twist of the century.
This candle is getting better and better.
You really know how to keep me entertained.
Share more tea, sweetheart.
Okay, fuck.
Please just let me inside.
Oh man, I would love to share any more tea, but I even have
photos on my phone, and I need to be inside to share that to
you.
Wait, you have actual photos?
Okay, spell it.
I'm dying to see the evidence, but let's keep exclusive just
between you and me.
Show me those pics, darling!
Um.
Let me inside your house, girlfriend, and I'll show you all
the photos you want.
Oh my gosh, you've earned yourself an exclude Let me in, let
me in, let me in Oh my god, just let me in already Jesus
Christ Get over here and Gina, fuck you Oh my god Holy shit
Finally.
Fuck you, Regina.
Jesus Christ.
That took me fucking forever to get into Regina's house.
Oh my god.
Final raid boss defeated.
That is like so not fair.
It's literally gone, girl.
Jesus Christ, bro.
Fuck Regina.
Oh, bitches, I ate Regina.
Oh my god.
i can't believe i got in the regina's house where is her
outfit oh no that's the weeb i don't want that's the brony
weeb no i need to i need to absorb regina all right now i'm
regina there should be add like they should add 10 to the
score all right no please no i want to be regina I can't
believe like Regina didn't want to fucking hear about the
gossip until like no he took my hair my beautiful hair he
took my hair oh my god that's fucked up that's fucked up he
actually took my beautiful hair oh my god who am I gonna be
I guess I'll just I'll be Regina but better
Alright, knock knock Oh hey there What brings a Barbie fan
like you at my door In the middle of the night An autograph
sign?
Or did you finally find Ken's missing shoe?
Okay, Tommy Twizzler He is a movie star Um, my Okay, I can
be like an also movie star Hello fellow movie Regina George
is a massive deal Tom, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fuck, okay.
What is our, what is our strat with Tommy?
What do we, what do we want to tell Tommy?
You are enough?
He's me.
Fuck, okay.
Um.
Oh, I got a damsel in distress.
Oh my God.
Tommy, my car broke down and I don't know anything about.
cars.
Oh, but my cars can be a real pain.
Well, lucky for you I'm a bit of a mechanic myself, which
seems to be the problem.
Oh my, you big, strong man's gonna help me fix my car.
no no i'm losing him i'm losing him just don't expect me to
be some kind of superhero or anything cars can be tricky you
know okay i could be like oh i didn't know that i'm so
stupid
oh my god fuck okay um i'm losing him i'm losing him what do
i say i'm what do i say don't be so he's not that
self-absorbed y'all build him up god damn it i don't know
what to say
um uh don't freak okay wait you can change just want to try
and make it not i can't do I'm a fucking V-Tuber.
Everything's gonna be awkward.
Tell him you need help with the exhaust pipe.
Oh my god.
Alright.
You're so right, Tommy.
Cars are so tricky.
I hope you can help me fix my car and help me.
Oh, well, I'll certainly give my best shot.
I can't promise anything about do what I can to help you.
Let's go take a look at your car and see if you can figure
out the problem.
Alright, fuck.
Okay, I don't have a car, though.
I don't have a car.
Wait, wait.
Oh, I'm so stupid.
I forgot to mention it was actually a flat tire.
Do you have a spare tire inside your house?
I don't keep spare tires in my house.
That's more of a garage thing.
But don't worry, we can still fix it.
I grab the tools and we can change the tire outside.
Sounds good.
Sounds great, Tommy.
Thank you so much for helping me.
How can I ever repay you before I kill you?
No need to worry about that.
I'm just happy to help up.
Maybe you can treat me to a cup of coffee or something when
we're done.
Oh, Tee-hee.
Oh, no.
Fuck, okay.
It's okay.
He'll be dead anyway.
Hmm.
Of course, Tom.
Can I call you Tom?
I would love to have a cup of coffee with you.
I've heard of you, huh?
Sure thing.
Tom works for me.
Coffee sounds great.
Let's focus on changing that tower first.
And then we can grab it.
that cup of coffee and chat some more deal?
Please just let me in!
Let me in!
Oh my god.
Alright.
I'm so tired, Tom.
Can I rest inside while you help me with my car?
Look.
Look, I can't let you in my house.
It's not personal or anything, but I just don't think it's a
good idea.
We can finish fixing your car and then you can rest in your
own vehicle or find a...
What the fuck?
Bro!
What do you think I'm gonna fucking steal stuff?
Tom!
You think I'm gonna steal stuff from you, Tom?
Why don't you trust me?
He's hiding something.
something he doesn't want me to okay okay i'm gonna use the
toilet oh my god i i need to use the toilet real quick tom
please i stand you but i can't let you use my but it's best
that you find a nearby public restroom what is he gonna slam
the door the coffee
i don't what about the coffee tom Tom, I see you fucking
bitch.
What about the coffee?
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
He's not gonna come inside, right?
No, he's not.
Okay.
Alright.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe he wouldn't give me the fucking coffee.
I can't believe he would just slam the door on me like that.
That's so fucked up.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
I didn't see him.
Don't take my outfit.
Please.
Don't take the gun.
Don't take the gun, officer.
Oh, thank God you didn't take the gun.
Okay, you didn't take the gun.
You didn't take the gun.
Bro, Tommy's so fucking rude.
Fuck Tommy.
I'm not gonna talk to Tommy ever again.
Fuck that guy.
Stop.
Hey there.
What brings a lumberjack arms?
with an AK-47 to my doorstep.
Wait, is this Mr. Beast?
That's one way to chop down any unwanted visitors.
Fuck, what does Mr. Beast like?
Hello, I traveled from Canada just to hand you a singular
penny.
Well, gee, golly, thanks.
I appreciate the effort you put into traveling all the way
here just to give me a penny.
That's some real dedication.
all right um that's not all mr east i also bought all your
mr east burgers and your mr east chocolates oh wow you
really went all out didn't you the mr eats burgers and
chocolates are my pride and joy so i'm thrilled to hear you
enjoyed it you're already a true mr east man
Fuck, okay, what else does Mr. Eastlakes going on in a
parish social the Eastable?
I would love to discuss with you some new ideas and flavors
for Eastables.
That's music to my ears.
I'm always up for some tasty new ideas.
Let's brainstorm and create some mind-blowing Eastables
together.
You've definitely earned an invite inside.
Oh my god.
Shit, okay.
We have to talk to you more?
That's so easy.
It's so easy to get into a content creator's house.
It's actually pretty scary how easy that was.
Okay.
I can't wait to feast, Mr. East.
I mean, there's a lot.
Woohoo!
Get ready for a feast of epic proportions, my friend.
Come on in, and let's dive into some mouth-watering
Easterboats together.
Alright, nice.
Little did he know he was a feast all along.
You never expect how this video ends.
Oh my god, I can be Mr. East.
Okay, wait, this is great.
I can be Mr. East, guys.
This is great.
I need a 5 Mr. East's house.
It's so fucking gullible.
You can't believe Mr. East.
Plus one.
As a content creator, I knew the inside to a content
creator's heart.
I knew what he wanted.
And he wanted content.
The East is slain.
Alright, is this Mr. East?
Okay, now I'm Mr. East.
all right next victim has speaking rhyme has a challenge
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you he got the
content that's all he wanted all right it's over there oh my
god who lives over here mr east finally canceled for good
after coming up with a plan to feed starving children with
east of us no no you'll never get my fucking easy outfit no
Leave me alone.
No, don't come inside.
Don't come inside.
He's not going to take it.
He's not going to take my Mr. East outfit.
He's never going to take my Mr. East outfit.
No matter what, he'll never be Mr. East.
Okay.
Not the neighborhood.
Watch.
No one's going to take my Mr. East outfit.
All right.
Okay, we need to Know what tool is up there I need to know
who lives up here Who lives up here in this mansion Toga,
welcome to the tomato farm Welcome, welcome
Who's this?
Elon suck What's popping like How can I assist you my tech
savvy Amigo?
Okay Okay
Mr. Elam I have a great idea for you For the next big video
Oh wow, Mr. East I'm all ears Spilled at these What's this
epic video idea that's gonna make waves In the tech world
Okay, okay, okay Now I need to think of an actual idea Okay,
now guys give me a sec i didn't think he would actually ask
me what the idea was i thought i could say that and then
he'll just be like don't worry here are the funds that's it
okay um i okay wait okay we need to think of a video idea a
real video idea that mr east would do buried underneath for
24 hours now imagine i was buried for 24 hours but with
iphones
um that sounds uh interesting but i'm not quite sure how
burying us up an iphone will be the next big thing thanks
for sharing my brain i can't invite you in the moment but
it's with iphones
It's with an iPhone!
That's the next big thing!
That's a new thing!
Like, imagine all the free advertising for iPhone!
Oh, hello there, Mr. East.
What brings you to my doorstep at this ungodly hour?
Okay.
Congratulations, Karen!
I will need you to be...
be in my next Mr. East video.
Oh, well, isn't that just thrilling?
But before I make my grand debut, I'll need to know all the
details.
Who else will be featuring alongside me?
Okay, who else?
Who's the other uh...
Uh, stop a plier?
Stop a plier?
I don't know.
Mark a plier.
What?
What is this world's markiplier?
Who is, who is this world's markiplier?
Regina.
Elon Musk.
It was Elon Zuck.
Elon Zuck said that he would like to be in this video.
Imagine being in a video with Elon Zuck, Karen.
I love Elon Zuck, seriously?
That's not you.
What do you mean?
I just talked to him.
To be in some silly video with.
Wait, he was real, Karen.
He's real to me.
He was real to me.
I can't believe it.
I swear he exists.
Someone will be in my...
Mr. East video.
Who's this?
Well, well, well.
Look who five decides to leave his mom's basement.
What brings you to the real world, Mr. YouTube's sensation?
Did you find...
Excuse you.
I am Mr. I'm not even going to talk to her.
Look at this.
If she doesn't understand the importance of Mr. East, then
she does not deserve to be eaten.
Hello, Mr. East.
It's positively delightful to see you at such a an hour i'll
simply spend it what brings you to my humble boat good sir
you want to be in my mr east video oh my wanted honor would
be in your mr east video i simply cannot contain my
excitement count me in dear sir to be in my mr east video we
need you to sign a contract to make sure we are not liable
for your safety is that okay
oh dear a contract that sounds absolutely terrifying i'm
afraid i just can't handle the stress i miss bid you good
farewell goods but what about my mr east video what do you
mean no one wants to be in my mr east video
please what do you want mysteries can't you see i'm already
drowning in the depths of my Mr. East video.
Who would sign a restrictive cut?
Are you serious?
You think I would be part of your mainstream self-help
video?
No thanks.
I'll stick to my underground edgy scene.
Okay, but Fallout Roy, this video is for the underground
edgy scene.
We're making it different.
Really?
Well, if it's really going to be unique and truly a spirit
of the scene then maybe i'll consider it but don't expect me
to sell my soul or compromise my artistic integrity okay
fuck okay any like artistic people here
who won't compromise artistic integrity who what do they
like i'm a i'm a vtuber i'm willing to compromise my
artistic integrity
Fuck, okay, I, um, you know what, Roy?
Because I like your style.
I'll even give you creative control.
Wait, seriously?
Creative control?
That's like the dream, man!
Alright, you've piqued my interest.
I'll let you in, but only because you seem to understand the
importance of artistic freedom.
Come on, what the fuck, it was that easy.
Okay, I'm gonna kill this guy now.
I'm in.
This is so mainstream.
Holy shit.
That was actually the easiest.
That's all it took.
That's really...
That's really all it took.
I just went like, yeah.
Artistic integrity.
Was it really that easy?
Apparently, all they care about is artistic integrity.
I can't believe it.
Don't get scammed.
Oh my god.
Influencers and artists.
Please love yourself more.
Please.
Okay, let me...
Now I look...
I look fancy.
Oh, it's a carrot.
Oh my gosh, what fabulous surprise.
Are you here to give me a sneak peek of the new spring
collection?
Or maybe spill some...
Oh no, I'm not.
I don't want to talk.
I already went through Regina.
Because I don't want to go through another Regina.
I'm so done.
Oh my god.
Wait, that's my shirt.
My shirt.
There's no more tea.
I'm so done with tea, guys.
I've had enough fill of tea chat.
Regina trauma.
Hello?
Oh, shit.
Tommy.
You're the most fabulous I've seen all day.
How about we hit the town and strut your... Okay.
Bro, are they all fashion people?
Please!
I don't want to deal with fashion.
I'm so over it.
I'm so fucking over fashion right now.
I'm so done.
I don't want to gossip anymore.
Oh my god!
A fellow enthusiast of scientific eccentric.
Welcome, welcome.
what brings you to my lair at this ungodly hour as a fellow
scientist I've heard about your research all the way from
Canada Canada a splendid land of hockey and maple syrup I'm
delighted to hear that my research has reached such far
reaches.
Tell me, what exactly have you heard about my groundbreaking
work?
Fuck, okay.
What has he done?
Does anyone know what pinky brains have done?
Does anyone know?
The jetpack!
Obviously, the jetpack.
No one has been able to successfully jetpacked ever.
You are the first one, sir!
The jetpack!
Jetpack!
A marvel of modern science indeed!
But I must admit, my dear friend, the jetpack is just the
tip of the iceberg in my grand plat- What?
How do you fucking do world domination with a fucking
jetpack?
It's a jetpack.
It's literally like you fly.
You can't dominate anything with whatever.
This scientist ain't so bright, actually.
of course oh my god you know what you're right fuck the
world I just said that oh um it seems you're feeling rather
distraught tries his best we postpone what do you mean the
world what
he was good at dominating the world Give me the throw.
You had him.
I blew it.
So, world domination?
You caught into my grand ambition, I see.
Yes, world domination is my ultimate goal.
With my brilliant mind, impeccable sense of style, nothing
can stand in my way.
Okay.
Okay, okay, we're back here.
I don't know why he didn't question why I just said world
domination, but that's okay.
We're back in it We're back in it.
He wants to dominate not this story.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
So world domination and chill
How dare you mock my crap?
What?
Leave at once before I'd unleash my fashionable fear.
What do you mean?
I should never I don't know why you know this is your fault
whoever whoever whoever's idea that was to say world
domination and chill that was on you that was on you that
was your fault all right I got an idea
okay hello I come in peace But also...
World domination?
A fellow mastermind with ambitions for world domination!
I must say, your sense of style and choice of accessories do
intrigue me.
Pray tell, what diabolical plans do you have in mind?
Well, fellow earthling, my alien friends and I are
planning...
on abducting the president
how dare you suggest such a I will not be part of your
misguided attempt to disrupt world order leave at once what
do you want your world domination what do you want
if you don't how are you supposed to do world okay I'm just
gonna ask him I need know what his plans are now i'm
confused now now i'm confused why i don't know what else do
you do for world domination what are your plans for world
domination ah my dear time traveling friend world domination
is indeed my ultimate goal my plan invite You don't
understand.
It's all about the jet pack.
My plans involve harnessing the power of mind control and
creating an army of loyal minions to carry out my bidding.
How is that?
How is that better than abducting the president?
Like, how is that better?
Shouldn't that be worse?
Like...
Okay, just say yes.
All right.
Excellent.
Together we shall conquer the world with our genius and
scientific powers.
But first, we must discuss the details of our master plan.
Step inside my laboratory, my newfound Conrad.
Yes.
Very creepy.
I'll officially welcome you to the rank of my loyal minions.
Together, we shall unleash chaos and rule.
And it was that easy.
All I have to say was yes.
He just wanted the yes man.
Oh my god.
Alright, let's see what love bites is.
I need to know what love bites.
Convince guests to break up with their loves Deliver breakup
letter and give them advice Watch the drama you caused
Unfold Just keep saying yes Alright let's break some hearts
Wait that's fun Alright Who are we?
Grandma Mudd Alejandro Jay Gatsby Wait oh my god what the
fuck
Okay, who is, who is, what the fuck, beast?
Oh my god, okay, the beast.
What do you want, festival creature?
Stop bothering me and my bell.
Bell told me you're ugly in the beast form.
How dare I have no time for your lies.
Leave me and my bell alone.
No!
Okay.
you're more like listen to someone they trust and like i'm
likeable
okay wait okay okay okay wait this is it all right we can do
this okay okay what do you want human can't you see i'm
trying to enjoy this dreadful party okay i heard from the
grapevine that Belle was talking to Gusto Gaston I heard
from the grapevine That Belle was talking to Gaston
How dare you spread such lies about Belle Leave once before
What?
Okay Fuck okay Okay maybe Oh I have an idea I have an idea I
have an idea I'll just I'll I'll, like, riz him up a little
bit, so I'm more believable.
He's so loyal!
Get that flashy package before I turn into confetti.
Hey, you're looking pretty good today, Beast.
Flatter won't save you from the rap.
Be gone, Salce!
Oh, my God.
He only has eyes for one person.
And it's only Belle.
Where's Belle?
Maybe Belle is easier to trick.
fuck is bell maybe all i have to do is trick bell he's loyal
all right why is he so loyal where the fuck is bell wait
does a police officer have like frank oh hey frank who's
move along citizen where's where's bell I can't be Be gone,
wench There's I only have eyes for one Person Where the fuck
is Where the fuck is A bell I can't find her Where is she
Where the fuck is she There's Mr. Darcy Where the fuck is
he?
Get her to leave.
It's easier.
I know I'm trying to find Bella.
There's Prince Char...
Oh, there she is.
There she is.
Okay.
Oh, la, la.
Bonjour, monsieur.
What delightful surprise.
May I ask what lovely give you bring to this?
Okay.
You are looking so wonderful in that dress.
Oh, merci, monsieur.
Your words are as sweet as a French macaron.
Do you dance the salsa as beautifully as you compliment,
perhaps?
We, mademoiselle, would you care to have a dance with me?
Oh, how...
Bro, she's... What the fuck?
The beast had its eyes for one person.
But Belle, Belle is willing to dance with me.
She ain't so innocent as we thought she was.
the pieces are better fuck okay what do we tell her she's
for the streets oh my god all right
madame did i ever tell you how beautiful you look in
moonlight oh monsieur your words are like sonnet set in the
romantic light of the moon what a charming heart you have
tell me do you truly believe such words or do you simply
have the tongue of a severed serpent oh my god beast you
deserve so much better why mademoiselle Of course I speak
the truth.
You are the most beautiful women I've seen tonight.
Oh, monsieur, your words warm my heart like a cozy fire on a
winter eve.
Tell me, do you see me as more than just a pretty face in
this dazzling ballroom?
Of course, mademoiselle, it's not just your looks, but your
brain as well.
truly an intellectual
pardon monsieur but your words ring hollow like an empty
carriage what use is flatter it falls upon ears already
worried I must take my leave now no I was so close I was so
close
no I choked she doesn't like to be complimented what about
her brain question mark she doesn't like to be said that
she's smart
the word brain is not romantic i'll save the piece oh my god
i can't believe brain isn't considered romantic okay all
right what do you find such fabulous attire Okay.
Um.
I was inspired by you, Bell.
You're looking gorgeous tonight.
Oh, you're too kind, mona me.
Merci beaucoup.
Do tell me, did you learn any dance moves for tonight's
celebration?
Okay, I can try this again.
Of course.
And can I kindly ask you to be my dance partner tonight?
Oh, la la.
just dance with me just like that, Belle?
Bro, he's right there.
Belle!
He's right there!
Oh, Freda, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Um, okay.
Yes, of course, Mademoiselle!
Let me sweep you off your feet.
Wahoo!
Mondeau, you are so charming.
I cannot wait to dance with you, but tell me, have you
always been such a smooth salsa dancer?
Um, fuck, okay.
Um, we all had to start somewhere.
But you, Belle, you inspire me to improve, mona me.
Oh, so sweet of you to say.
to have inspired you.
Tell me what motivates you the most in your salsa dancing
journey.
My motivation is please stop.
This feels like a job interview.
Okay.
No, I'm not gonna fumble it.
I am not gonna fumble it.
this time okay um what motivates you the most in your salsa
dancing journey when i close my eyes mon and me i imagine
being able to dance with you in the future just like today
well we're doing like poetry i imagine our future dances
together fill my heart with joy
Shall we?
Why, of course, monsieur, take my hand.
Unchante, let's dance our hearts up on the me.
Bro, he's like right there.
He's like right there.
I can't just say yes.
We met.
Belle
Wee, wee, belle No!
Oh, wee, let's twirl and roll With passion and grace,
monsieur Our dance is like a beautiful story Unfolding
before her eyes Okay, okay Wee, wee, okay, okay, we have to
Okay, okay, we have to make sure Break up with Mr. Beast Mr.
Beast Belle We can't This is forbidden You have to end it
with Miss with the beast If we have we can be together Okay
Is that Do you think I'm Do you think we're at the stage
Where she will break up with the beast Do you think we're at
that stage Do you think
No?
Belle What do I say?
too far?
Not yet.
What do I say, though?
Too fast?
Bell, do you feel the same way I do about you?
Your question brings a cloud of doubt if O'Neill could be
completely sure.
I need to be a moment.
No!
And they have a hand.
Bell, no!
No!
so close.
Bell, please, break up with him.
What's so just as delivery, driver?
Okay.
Manami, I have a package for you.
Excuse me, moi?
I do not recall any packages.
I must bid you invest.
But you had the plus!
You had the plus!
Oh my god.
We were so close!
We were so fucking close!
Keep it simple and sure.
It's a fumble!
Bell, please!
Leave him!
Kill a surprise to see you here at the Valentine Park.
Dress as a therapist.
What secrets do you hope to recover, monomy?
Okay.
As your therapist, I wanted to ask you if you are okay.
Oh, la, la.
I'm touched by your concern, Missy, a therapist.
I'm quite alright.
Just a little bored with the lack of excitement in my life.
Do you have any thrilling stories to share with you?
No, okay.
For, like, this breaks all confidentialities between patient
and therapist.
And also, I'm pretty sure, like, it's very illegal for a
therapist to, like, try to date their patients, too.
so anyway um well i have an exciting story to tell you i
think i think i have a crush on one of my clients oh la la a
forbidden love story between therapists and client quekel
intrigue tell me more about this mysterious amor that's
captured your heart monsieur therapist the tea she wears a
she wears a crown and a beautiful white dress but she's
taken by another beast
mandua this tale of unrequited love touches my heart have
you tried discussing your feelings with someone you trust
monsieur monsieur therapist this is illegal
It's yellow?
It's white!
What do you mean?
It's the lighting.
Yes.
Yes, this is why I told you.
I trust you a lot, Belle.
Oh, la la.
I am honored, but I must admit, I'm feeling tad flustered by
the weight of your feelings.
Perhaps we should focus on helping you navigate this
delicate situation first.
Fuck, okay, okay, okay.
What do you think I should do about this unrequited love?
Perhaps expressing your feelings honestly.
Yet respectfully could lead a resolution.
Okay.
I'm so...
I don't
Okay, yes
No It would not be time to have a catty With the object
you're finished And as for me, I realized that it might be
time to write a letter of my own To my own beast No Wait,
that's come that my therapist has a crush On a client who is
taken by another beast Making me realize it's time for me to
Go on my own, goodbye dear Oh, wait, that worked.
That worked.
I made her realize.
I did.
Wait, that doesn't make sense.
I did it, though.
I did it.
I just said yes.
Oh, my God.
Okay, as a question was saying, I'm not making me realize
it's time for me to go on my own adventure.
I know you're having a great time dancing, There's a letter.
He has some crush you have on Tal who is with another beast.
I think it's not fair what she did to you.
And demand an explanation for her actions.
Is that it?
You've been so distant and cold lately, I can't take it
anymore.
Fell, I think it's not fair what she did to you.
But now, I think we should break up.
I can't do this anymore.
Break up?
Fine.
I saw the way you were eyeing that enchanted teapot.
And don't think I didn't notice that.
Oh, my God.
I just want to thank them for the hard work.
But now I think we should pour a teapot.
Please, I am done with this.
nonsense I don't want to be with someone who can't
appreciate a good fairy tale romance fine be that way I'll
just be go back to the castle and soak with Lumion Cogsworth
at least they understand me goodbye Bella yay I did it I did
it yay a happy ending I did it
Mrs. Potts.
A teapot?
What the fuck?
Yay.
No love for you.
Look, he's dancing, though.
He seems to be having a good time dancing.
Are you okay?
Are you okay, Beast?
What did I just with this?
I don't know.
I should have just said yes earlier.
I feel like just saying yes just solves all my problem.
He's dancing his pain away.
Oh my god.
I didn't realize all I had to do was say yes.
That's all.
I think that's a good way to call it.
I think that's a good way.
Breaking up Beauty and the Beast.
I did it.
I will never trust the therapist anymore.
Lou, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
With the power of yes.
That's really all it took, guys.
Just keep saying yes.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
It's so much better than Twilight.
Just yes.
That was fun, though.
That was really, really fun.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
That was...
Um, um, that was actually so fucking funny though, uh, um,
but that was, that was,
I actually did not expect how fun it was to, to just mess
around with chat, like, to mess around with chat GPT slash
AI and just like the type of conversations uh the type of
conversations we have with a ai uh but yeah that was i hope
you guys enjoyed that i know some of you were asking i
figured out my pal world twitch rivals team i have not
except for sure for sure for uh i asked sure for if he
wanted to join me because um he really really likes pal
world so that is the only teammate i have right now.
That is the only teammate I've confirmed in PAL World.
For those who are wondering what is the tournament going to
be like it's basically like an achievement run thing.
So they're going to give us a list of achievements and then
we're supposed to we're supposed to like try and see how
many achievements we can get done in like two days
basically.
So it's going to be very interesting because I was like, oh
wow, PAL World Twitch Rivals.
How the fuck that's going to work right thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you uh but yes i have no
confirmations on who else will be my teammates um i haven't
really looked at like people um asked yet i really haven't
looked on my uh twitter thread so i'll figure that out later
also also i'm really excited about the charity auction
because there was a lot of like amazing talented creators
that wanted to like wanted to like help out and work with me
on collabing on some one of a kind dokey items we actually
had like I was talking about this on the chat the waiting
room chat but basically like I grew up with watching not
grew up sorry I loved watching like custom doll
customization like those who like customized like you know
um what is it called the the fuck was that like the high
like those that did like monster high dolls and stuff and
they customized monster high dolls to like make it look into
like different things like i used to watch a lot of doll
lifeo and stuff like that so um a custom doll maker actually
reached out to me and said they'll make a yeah ball jointed
dolls like they'll make they want to make a custom dokey
ball jointed doll to sell for the auction which is um which
will be really fun and i'm really looking forward to that
too amazing talent there's a lot of plushy makers a lot of
like figure makers and like a lot of like talented artists
that wanted to like do some one of a kind items and stuff to
sell at an auction um anyway guys uh i am gonna call it here
i would love to do like a super chat reading right now but
because i have a second stream i want to relax a little bit
before the second stream and i'll read the super chats on
the second stream but thank you everybody for coming to the
first stream I am doing Batman later.
So if you guys want more, I'll be streaming part two of
Batman.
I want to do, like, a little bit of a long stream for Batman
because I think I want to try and finish the game by this
week.
So by, like, the end of the week, I'll have Batman done.
But, yes, thank you, everybody, for calling.
You guys had a great time watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flow.
any of you stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it
i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye